salut c'est jimmy et j'espère que vous
allez bien de votre côté et que surtout
vous restez à la maison
aujourd'hui je vous emmène au voyage une
fois de plus dans confiné d'ici et
d'ailleurs direction la réunion ont
partout tu te retrouves et pascal lorent
sin en direct de la réunion aujourd'hui
c'est un plaisir d'échanger avec toi
pascal thurre martiniquais et eu via la
réunion depuis combien de temps
puis 10 qu'est ce qui t'a amené à partir
aussi loin de la martinique alors je dis
aussi loin parce que la réunion ne me
semble que c'est plus de 24 heures de
vol pour y aller depuis chez nous et
comment tu t'es retrouvé à la réunion
t'écoutes j'envie dire opportunité j'ai
saisi l'opportunité de pouvoir mettre à
bien ici dans mon domaine d'activité
puisque j'ai suivi quatre sportifs
sachant que c'est un département qui est
en fait le sportif tout le monde
pratique un sport
la réunion s'est très très beau tous les
gens qui sont allés qu'on utilise en
reviennent il dit c'est vraiment
magnifique
il ya des canyon il ya des montagnes qui
sont absolument sublime
est-ce que tu as eu l'occasion déjà
depuis le temps que tu es là 18 mois
tout juste parce que tu as eu le temps
de visiter un petit peu de découvrir
libre ah oui c'est vrai qu'un problème
des rocades mais il reste nature
mécanique
le volcan qui est en permanence en
activité et j'ai mieux effectivement
disions pas beaucoup beaucoup
d'occasions pour en faire pas mal de
balade ensoleillée lever du soleil
gallego qui déneigent nous petites
choses à faire et nature en parlant des
requins justement parce que on a
beaucoup entendu parler ces derniers
temps
toi qui viens de la martinique et qui
connaît les belles plages les salines
lance couleuvres et compagnie est-ce que
c'est totalement différent est ce qu'on
va à la plage à la réunion comme on
irait à la plage en martinique le
week-end oui on va à la plage à la page
et tous les jours et moi je suis du côté
ouest
c'est à saint gilles les bains là il ya
plus de touristes est effectivement
matin la page ne comptait pas j'ai
beaucoup plus développé les bars de
plage et c'est effectivement pour la fac
tous les jours est pratiquement à l
appel de l école les jeunes ce recours
pour prendre l'apéro en revanche si
belle pardon on retient en fait le
projet s'arrête on concède du serveur
laisse pendre développer activement et
serveurs qui n'hésite pas à mettre en
mouvement
mais jean venir justement cette période
de confinement un peu particulière
comment vous le vivez vous à la réunion
j'imagine puisque c'est un département
français que les mêmes règles
s'appliquent là bas est-ce que les gens
sont
est-ce que vous avez beaucoup de cas de
corps on a un virus à la réunion est ce
qu'il ya déjà eus et malheureusement des
décès alors on parle
11 350 cas en ce sens dans les trois
personnes qui étaient en réanimation
donc c'est vrai que ma des chiffres
satisfaisants
maintenant le confinement est plus ou
moins après un arrêt de trois semaines
un mois maintenant conscient et lucide
et les gens je pense effectivement le
souci de sentir et de croiser des ombres
d'aller à l'écart par cher parce que
c'est vrai qu'au début de conditions
d'hygiène des siècles télépathie n'est
pas du tout respecté et les gens
continuent elles à la plage même dans ma
résidence amis à une semaine les gens
faisait encore des barbecues avec la
fête
il se retrouvait à la piscine pour cent
de la paix dans le privé dans le public
effectivement marqué nantissement de
l'activité je pense que plus chez les
gens qu'est ce qui te manque le plus
pascal par rapport à la martinique dans
ta nouvelle vie à la réunion qui avait
quelque chose de martinique que tu
pourrais emporté avec toi en permanence
ce serait quoi la plage peut-être de
pouvoir se baigner ici c'est possible
mais c'est compliqué merci merci
beaucoup parce qu'à l'origine pour cette
petite visite dans ton quotidien et puis
aussi dans un nouvel vivre
lyonnaise on espère te voir quand même
très bientôt sur une des plages de
martinique et de pouvoir vraiment
profiter sans aucun souci d'un bon belle
mère parce que nous les requins c'est
réglé on n'a pas et puis quand un film
anglais donc ça la crise merci en tout
cas merci beaucoup
pascal lorent sin et puis bon
confinement prudence à très bientôt
voilà confiné d'ici et d'ailleurs est
maintenant terminée on se retrouve très
bientôt sur la première d'ici là restez
à la maison et prenez soin de vous
[Musique]